foreign
dress real sexy and provocative that
they're pretty much asking for attention
from men I don't even know really how to
handle that and when he mentions it
around the girls because if something
were to happen to one of them I don't
want them to ever think it would be
because they dressed a certain way this
isn't sitting well with you there's
something else going on here what is
that
[Music]
come on with the doctor John deloney's
show and I'm so glad that you are with
us
the most important podcast on the planet
possible overstatement but barely barely
overstating how important this show is
the greatest mental health and marriage
podcast ever I'm so glad that you've
joined us and if you are new to the show
clearly I'm joking this is we are
figuring this out as we go so grateful
that you're with us if you want to be on
the show go to John deloney.com ask
a-s-k or give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 leave a message and Jenna
or Kelly will give you a buzz and call
you back and I've been out of town for a
few for I don't know a few weeks but for
a while and it feels good to be home a
little bit good sometimes that hotel
life is dope all right let's go to
um
let's see here
let's try Jen in
Michigan do they rhyme that's pretty
cool what's up Jen and from Michigan
Hi how are you dancing like I've never
danced before ever
we'd be dancing in the snow here so oh
gross is it cold it's gross yeah it's
fun there's fun today so it's okay
[Music]
that's how you know you're living right
when you're like it's miserable but
their son so we're good yeah yeah gotta
look for the positive you don't have to
but it helps all right so what's up Jen
how can I help
um so my question is how do I learn how
to give more affirmation without feeling
fake
um
well
a little backstory my husband and I were
your favorites for high school
sweethearts oh did y'all watch Dawson's
Creek I don't wanna wait no no okay well
good for you I always wanted to have a
high school sweetheart I just didn't
work out for me okay so good for you
oh yeah so we've been together for 25
years we've been married for 18 this
year
um we have four kids we they're 10 12 14
and 16.
um we also have a bonus student right
now she's our exchange student from um
Italy so we have a very Full House
um
my husband he's one of like
the most energetic positive people
um his
love language is definitely affirmation
and mine is not so his being affirmation
he's very good at giving affirmation and
mine is acts of service so I'm not so
good at giving it
[Music]
um
but two of the four kids that we have
got the affirmation love language and it
is very hard for me to give them the
affirmation I will be able to say it in
my head I'll tell them but I'm proud of
them in my head or you know that they
did a good job or but when I try to
actually get it out it just there's like
a disconnect for some reason I just
can't
say it without feeling like they're
gonna think I'm fake or
like it doesn't mean anything I don't
know
why does your body react negatively to
praise
I don't know
um
I want to challenge your language a
little bit
um okay
you've got to stop talking in terms of I
can't
or I feel
okay all four of your kids
are in Desperate Like Oxygen need of
affirmation
whether you think you've identified two
that need it and two that don't all four
of your kids and your husband and
contrary to what some dumb internet
survey might have told you you need it
too
but something about giving it and
receiving it makes your body feel
awkward or weird where does that come
from
definitely makes me cringe though when
somebody gives me information
why don't you think you're worthy of
affirmation
foreign
like and I'm just going to run through
some stuff do you think you're too good
for it do you like yeah I know I'm
incredible did your parents do such a
great job pumping you up that
um when you hear it you're like duh I
know that I'm the best in this room
or is it the op like what is it about
affirmation
it is the opposite for sure okay
what do you feel like you're gonna lose
when your 12 year old comes be-bopping
in and worked her butt off or his butt
off on something and did a good job and
maybe not even a great job but a good
job
what do you think you're gonna lose
what's the net loss by saying hey come
here for a minute
and grabbing them on both sides of the
face and saying I saw how hard you
worked on this
incredible
I'm so proud of you
every day I thank God that I get to be
your mom it's awesome
now get out of here like when you when
you hear me run through that what do you
feel like you're gonna lose by doing
that
um
I I don't want to say yeah but I think
it's controlled I think
of them
I don't know treating me like mom
instead of a friend maybe
if that makes sense but I don't know if
that makes sense
tell me more I think it does but tell me
more
um
like
let me go to an example so I I coach
volleyball and I have a practice plan
out and whenever the girls will you know
be like what can we do this if it wasn't
in my plan or wasn't my idea it makes me
feel like
not just respected but one of those
words just like like I've lost control
of I'm no longer The Authority maybe I
don't like that word either but that's
what that you were
you are using Authority and positional
power and what I think is one of the
most disregarded and overused at the
same time words of our current ethos
which is I just want to be me is
authenticity
you're using those as ways to keep
people at arm's length from you what do
you think is going to happen if you
connect with somebody
did somebody leave you when you were a
kid
no did somebody hurt you when you were a
kid that was close to you
no what do you think you're gonna lose
because you're hedging your bets against
something
I really I really don't know
okay
I need you to hear me like super clear
you're a great mom and I can tell you
love your kids and I can tell there's
something stuck between you and that
relationship
and I'm saying this with all due respect
and love and care but those kids are
starving for it and your husband is too
and I promise you you are as well
and hiding behind it just has to be my
way just has to be the highway there is
something about being a coach and there
is something about uh being a parent and
having appropriate like you're not my
friend
but connectivity all let me put this way
all the research says is the more
connected a parent is as the children
are younger
the more autonomous and the more
risk-seeking they are as adults it's
counterintuitive
the more we want our kids to grow up and
be really strong and adventurous and
just go to the college or skip college
and go open the business whatever we
have to over connect with them
and so I'm just going to tell you this
as lovely as I can you're gonna have to
get over it and you're going to have to
decide I've got to practice and do these
things and when it feels awkward feel
the awkward and do it anyway
and your kids are probably gonna be like
what happened to you and it may be that
you have to
um I know a couple who struggles with
talking to each other
um he's really annoying and she finds
him annoying but she loves talking but
it just kind of comes up so they've just
both take into writing down notes in
their phone
and they call them talk topics that they
can just talk about when they get
together and it's kind of like when you
first have your first or second kid and
you gotta start putting sex on the
calendar and it doesn't feel as sexy as
romantic but it's either not going to
happen or we're gonna put on the
calendar it's very similar and I would
start making a list every day on a note
card on your app on your phone that just
says I will pull each kid aside and have
skin to skin contact and I'll look them
in the eye and tell them something
wonderful about them and you're not
making them weak and you're not making
them cowardly and more importantly
you're not diminishing your relational
Authority you're their mom they already
know that
how does that sound
it's good um
to write more notes because I can write
it down
like I said I just can't get it out like
I say it in my head I just can't get it
out what did anybody ever tell you
you're good growing up
um I mean yeah my parents they they were
good if I know my parents aren't overly
um
affectionate they weren't when we were
younger
um
so I don't know if that's just something
that I
taken from that where you know I I think
there's something else and I again
here's what where it's cool it doesn't
matter
you have to fix this you got to get this
one right
because I promise you because you the
fact that you're asking the question
tells me you feel that Gap too right
what about your husband
um has he ever said things like he
misses you or where are you
um yeah
yeah he's
he's kinda
filled in for me with the kids yeah
don't let that's uh I'm throwing a flag
on that one and yeah
sometimes the inability to praise is the
exact same pathology is over praise
yeah and he may be reaching for stars to
try to get something he's not getting
in his own home
yeah
is that fair
I would love love love love love you to
sit down tonight and ride out here are
some things that I think are wonderful
about my kids
and make a plan to start telling them
even if you would make a public
announcement at dinner tonight that said
I'm gonna begin practicing I love each
of you so much and it's so crazy how
Wild I am about you guys and how proud I
am of you all
that I'm going to begin making sure you
all know it and it's going to be weird
because this isn't anything mom has ever
done before but it's going to be new and
you're just gonna have to get over it
because I'm gonna tell you every day how
much I love you I'm gonna tell you every
day how much how proud I am of you
I'm gonna tell you every day that I saw
I caught you doing something right and
I'm gonna let you know about it and this
is you just practicing and then you look
at your husband dead in the eye and say
I realize that I under the guise of this
isn't my love language or whatever bull
crap that is
I have not given you the affirmation
that you need I'm sorry and I tell you
this uh here's what gin is important
when my marriage is on the brink
like hanging on by dental floss barely
I remember how embarrassed I was to tell
my wife I just want you to tell me that
you're proud of me
I worked so hard for you for this house
and I I'm ashamed to say that that would
give me that would be like water in the
desert but you tell me I'm praying she
told her her response was man that would
have been awesome to know 20 years ago I
didn't know you needed that
I do I do
[Music]
so make a commitment to him I'm gonna
say one nice thing in the morning I'm
gonna say one nice thing in the
afternoon I'm gonna ask him one question
about his day in the morning one
question in the afternoon
and it's also fair to say hey husband I
need this too here's what I need
but you got to do it no matter what and
how uncomfortable it is you got to
practice you got to practice you got to
practice
this is something you got to get right
our kids need us
your kids need you thank you so much for
the call Jim we'll be right back
I've got a word from our sponsor better
help listen I've been on both ends of
therapy in my life I've gotten it myself
and I've walked people through it and
I've seen the benefits from both sides
when someone owns their past and the
cracks in their armor but here's the
deal Getting to Know Yourself is not a
one-time event acknowledging the stories
that make you who you are can be a
lifelong process and talking through
things with the right sounding board
empowers you to change your future and
be the best version of yourself
so if you're thinking about starting
therapy I recommend better help better
help connect you with a licensed
therapist who can walk with you on that
journey of self-discovery and it's a
hundred percent online and it's designed
to be convenient flexible and work for
your schedule just fill out a quick
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and if it's not the
right fit you can switch therapists at
any time for no additional charge visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back um and Jen is on
hold she's still in the line so she can
hear this Kelly what you were just
telling me something during the break
yeah so I
stand in because I I am Jan yes
um and
I growing up great parents they love me
very much and there wasn't a lot of
words of affirmation it was just this is
what you're expected to do you did it
great you succeeded in this now succeed
in the next thing
um we'll we'll let you know if you're
not doing it right kind of thing and
um so that wasn't modeled well so if you
made A's does you're supposed to exactly
if you don't that's where the problem
comes in or yeah you you made this dance
team in my case or you were you know
student counselor whatever those things
were expected and lots of love just not
a lot of hey we're really proud of you
and I can tell you once I heard my dad
say once I heard my mom say and I could
tell you where I was what room I was in
because it was so out of the ordinary
right and and it was so needed oh it was
just I just I mean I'm still holding on
to them 30 years later 40 years later
you know and but so when I had my kids I
had to make a and I still it's still
something I have to work on of
my my Norms my default is great you did
it you want a cookie right yeah great I
can't give you a sticker every time you
do something instead of and we had to do
it last night telling the kids God you
know y'all both handled the because you
know we're still in a rental house and
everything y'all handled this really
well
and praising kids for praising them for
when they do things and my husband
included it's something I have to I have
to make sure I give hugs in the morning
make sure I you know I say you know
something here it's still a checklist
for me because it's not my Norm so I
understand that but I've had to make it
a habit has to become part of it yeah
yeah and now I was just texting with my
son because somebody put something on
his phone that I didn't find appropriate
and he texted me this morning hey Mom I
just want you to know I changed that and
deleted it I was like I'm really proud
of you for making that decision because
I was going to make it for him this
evening
um and I'm ready for making that
decision
so what about what about vulnerability
feels like a loss of control oh
vulnerability my least favorite word it
because it just is a loss of control
it's okay that's so important that's
exactly what it is it is it is taking
control of
I am going to open the door a little bit
and you could kick this door into my
face right I might as well just take my
heart out lay it on the ground and let
you just Stomp all over it yes same
thing to me
and I so I get where she's coming from
because that is hard because I am not I
am a control freak I like control of
everything tell me more no Kelly
vulnerability is hard for me absolutely
and I've had to learn it through
counseling because it it happens
depended on it that's right parenting
and so I've had to learn it so it is a
skill it is something you have to learn
to do if it was not modeled for you yes
and there's no shame in it and it's
fantastic when you learn it
I think that's the important side
important thing on the other side of it
is the unfortunate thing about
relationships is the only way they work
is when
there's vulnerability when somebody
tells the truth
holding back Secrets whether they're bad
secrets and we often think when we think
Secrets like it's bad sometimes the
secret is God I'm so proud of you right
or my daughter walks in and I'm like
she's so beautiful and she gets so mad
at me when I tell her that she's
beautiful
like right
and if I don't tell her the good stuff
too that's I'm keeping secrets from them
right and so the only way it works is
vulnerability and I hate that I wish
there was another way I trust me I wish
there was another way there's just not
they're just not and not vulnerability
and weakness vulnerability in you could
hurt me you just said it right there to
me vulnerability has always been
weakness and that is my biggest fear is
to be perceived as weak gotcha and so
but learning that of hey I need to tell
my husband what I need or why this hurt
me or blah blah blah blah and then you
do it you're like oh I'll be darned if
that didn't work I thought I felt really
yeah and then he can go oh cool I'll
never do that again exactly let's go to
dinner and you're like oh you're like
wait wait what a problem solved yeah
yeah but it is a skill you have to learn
and it is something you have to practice
it's a list you have to check yeah you
know it's a listen you go yes I did that
I did that and then then it becomes a
normal part of your habit so something
that I think Jen could practice she
talked about being a volleyball coach it
may be that she schedules out practice
like she loves to do and then schedules
five minutes for at the end for them to
choose yeah do you want to do this drill
this drill or y'all want to do a quick
pick up right they get to pick yeah and
then it gives them a little bit of yeah
she's listening to us and it lets her
retain control right it's almost that
illusion if they're getting a choice
exactly to me all the time oh yeah you
want tacos or burgers and I'm like
that's what I'm talking about damn right
it's my house we're eating burgers is
she yeah exactly and the whole time she
knew exactly what was happening yeah
exactly so thank you for sharing that
that's that's that's importante
um all right let's go to Mary in
Indianapolis what's up Mary
hi doctor what's up
hey so okay so my question it's even
really a hard one to ask bring it on
stupid for asking it but hey Have you
listened to the show before quite a bit
you are all good man you're in good
there is no weird questions on this show
or hard questions what's up
well okay so my husband and I we have
nine kids together six are mine three
are his nine
nine
all right nine kids
okay yeah and five of them are girls
okay well he
and he is a military veteran and he's
real strong in his beliefs and things
but he says that when women dress real
sexy and provocative that they're pretty
much asking for attention from men and
things like that
okay
and I just I just I don't even know
really how to handle that and when he
mentions it around the girls because if
something were to happen to one of them
I don't want them to ever think it would
be because of you know it was ever
anything that they did or because they
dressed a certain way or you know
yes let's take them off first off the
table for a second this isn't sitting
well with you tell me why there's
something else going on here what is it
well for one because I don't believe
that okay tell me more and
and um two of the girls actually had um
an instance with an uncle where they
were touched inappropriately okay
and I guess that's where it hits home at
you for a while and he's best he was
best friends with that Uncle
and so is he blaming these girls
no but at the same time like he he
refuses to call him a pedophile which I
fully believe he's not allowed to be
around anyone in the family at all
anymore because I made a huge deal out
of it filed a police report told
everybody in the family everybody knew
that had little girls
and there wasn't like we had a
graduation party because the girls are
older now of course we had a graduation
party and he allowed him to be at the
graduation party
and
yeah I just like the kids shouldn't even
have to even see him in this being the
same room with him
but then also I don't want the girls to
think it's there why isn't he in jail
because the police said that um it was
just grooming and there was no evidence
of anything it was just his word against
their work grooming is a crime too why
isn't he in jail
that's what the detective told us
because they sent out crimes against
children genetic detective to the house
and that's what they told us even though
CPS has even been involved because he's
done things with his he got accused of
doing things should I say with his
daughter's friends
are these daughters all your biological
kids are they both
no they're my biological kids they're
older now it happened when they were a
lot younger one I didn't even find out
about until way later okay
I would not have these kids around that
man I would not have these kids around
your husband right now
that's just me
I'm not even around my husband
well he's got absolutely no regard for
their safety or care
yeah first I don't think he even
believed it but there's just been too
many allegations
and then since I came for since I made a
big deal about it and didn't keep it a
secret other people started coming up
because apparently a lot of people were
keeping things a secret they always do
it takes one person with some with
courage and bravery but the greatest
gift you can give your kids when they
tell you something like that is to
believe them
I want to do 100 that's what I mean it
actually involved the police if they got
a dad that doesn't
yeah
and then they've got a dad dummy and
here's why I'm digging into this yes
when I dress I'll just say me I'm an old
man when I dress nice I want people to
notice me and so I think it's it's not
it's not being genuine it's being it's
being dishonest to say no dude I'm just
dressing good and sexy and attractive
whatever because it just makes me feel
good that is true it does make me feel
good but I also want people to notice I
look nice I want people to think I'm
good looking that I'm handsome I'm not
beyond that that's fine and so whether
you're 14 or whether you're 40 or
whether you're 55 or whatever I think
there's some truth to that
and
I don't care about what anyone has to
say
if somebody an adult sexually assaults a
child
I don't care what that kid was wearing I
don't care what that kid was saying I
don't care what that kid was doing that
kid is a kid
and if there is any sort of
um suggestion that the kids have has a
role to play in an adult
abuse situation
I'll be out of that situation so fast
yeah he's not referring to the kids he
doesn't he's referring to like just
women in general because we were
watching the show and this guy was like
basically like harassing this woman
textually and then the guy was like well
you wore a shirt where I can basically
see through it and see your nipples
and then Greg was like well yeah that's
true she wanted that attention from him
or why else would she want it
you know that type of thing yeah because
Batman are hardwired for that type of
thing and that women shouldn't even be
allowed to wear certain things
here's the problem is that there's some
truth in all of it
if I wear a see-through shirt I want
someone to say something and that gives
nobody license to sexually assault me or
to harass me
and if I walk into a room and someone's
wearing a see-through shirt it's up for
to me to turn around and leave out of
honor of my wife out of respect for my
daughter out of respect for all sort
right so it's all of it all wound up
together
and so to say the way to solve this
problem I I love how it has been um
women need to be more modest and the
response has been over the last decade
or so or men could rape less right men
could sexually assault less it's it's
both and
it's both in
that's true
and so I think the
your husband is using this as something
there's something else here that you're
not telling me Mary and I don't know
what it is and if you don't tell me
that's fine
but there's something else that's not
right
you know I mean that's it it just it
really I think it just makes me fall out
the handle I think and I feel like I'm
being irrational because it just makes
me so mad when someone says something
like that have you told him that that I
think you're wrong
yeah and then he gets just gets real
defensive and I probably come at him
wrong because I get defensive because
like I said it just brings back all that
with the girls okay I recommend having a
non-defensive conversation about it
okay of you've heard me say this a
million times and it gets cliche after a
while but to go grab some lunch or go
grab breakfast and say hey I'm every
time this comes up these are my girls
and I'm a woman and I want to tell you
when you say this I think it's fair to
say somebody shows up to a bar in a
see-through shirt
yes they want people to look at them and
see that they're attractive Fair
that's fair
and
um
telling my teenage daughters
that they are responsible for the
actions of adults in their life that's
just not right so when he says this this
is what they're actually hearing and if
he cares about them and loves them he's
going to be careful about his language
and I think it's fair for them to
understand hey as a guy when you wear
this this is what I this is the story
that I'm telling myself
this is the story culture has told me
about you
right wrong or indifferent I'm just
letting you know I'm your dad that's
fair for me
so you see what I'm saying
yeah and he sounds like a guy that's
going to get all mad and blow you off
and at the end of the day you have to
choose do I want me and my daughters
around this or not
yeah he does a lot of times get real
defensive and angry at first then he'll
take a day or two and calm down and then
he'll come back okay after he thinks
about it for a while
that may be because you
you hear the light you hear it and you
hear it you hear it and then you blow up
then he blows up and now now we're not
even talking about the thing now we're
talking about who's right and who's
wrong who's got power in this
relationship and that no problems get
solved there
I think circling back to
um
hey I'm gonna have a hard conversation
with you and I want to take you to
breakfast and let's sit down and have
this discussion and it's going to be
uncomfortable for both of us I love you
I'm not going anywhere but we need to
have this talk
um
here's why this is important to me
um and then have it that way
um
I think that's a much that's a much
better
Avenue to have that talk does that make
sense does that feel good yeah yeah it
does because it usually ends up in a big
blah blah yeah and tell them I have no
interest in fighting with you I've got
no interest in blow-ups I have interest
in
letting you know here's how this is
hitting me here's how I'm afraid this is
hitting the girls
and you as Mom you've got a
responsibility to check in with modesty
and with
um discernment and responsibility and
love and here's the you that you're
presenting to the world with your
daughters your dad is a world I mean
your dad your husband has a role to play
in that also
but y'all gotta be on the same page with
this conversation and any side of this
conversation that gets out of whack and
gets accusing you can do whatever you
want and there's no or anybody could man
now you just gotta mess now you got a
mess you got a mess
I think the the the place to start here
is two adults having a hard conversation
together
and he is correct
when somebody walks into a bar right
wrong or indifferent
there's a story that's a cultural story
that's told
that's true
and
there is no license
ever
for unwanted sexual advances or sexual
assault or child abuse from molestation
any events ever
it tells you otherwise get away from
them as far as you can
[Music]
the messy with Mary thank you for the
call we'll be right back
hey good folks John deloney here I I
feel like I fell through a glitch in The
Matrix this is my job I get to have this
show do this show walk alongside each
one of you as a career this is what I do
and I have a blast doing it and me and
the team were so thankful for all of you
for being a part of our show whether
you're one of the original 17 or you're
one of the millions that's come since
then we are so grateful for you and we
want to put together the best possible
show that we can so if you're one of The
Originals or if you're brand new we want
your feedback tell us what you love
about the show what you hate about the
show would you like to see more of would
you like to hear more of and what you
want us to never do again you can email
us at askjohn ramsesolutions.com that's
askjohn ramseysolutions.com with your
feedback thank you for being such an
important part of the show rock on
all right we are back and man we sparked
it up with that last call okay we've
been talking for a long time off air all
right what were you saying Kelly
well I mean there is a
thing like just if we're just if you're
just tuning back in this is
a woman has had four biological
daughters I think her five daughters
um she got re she's remarried had nine
kids and several of them were sexually
abused by
um her new husband's brother
new husband then fast forward several
years later
um continues to let brought the abuser
around whatever and is really loud and
demonstrative about
women who dress a certain way are just
asking for it and they are putting the
vibe out because they want to be looked
at and they want to be whatever and so
this guy on the show they were watching
was being gropey and gross and he was
like well look what she's wearing
and I think I think we said it early
like both things can be true at the same
time right
and then Kelly okay so I got everybody
caught up but I was raised in that very
much of a
what you wear then
you put yourself in a bad position
because men are just incapable control
so freaking stupid yeah because if you
wear that whatever it is
um like I remember having to leave for
the water park in a one piece and then
changing into my bikini when I got there
um sorry Mom and Dad and because you
know we'll you you shouldn't wear that
because then yeah you you're the one
putting yourself in a bad situation in a
water park that you know because they
can't control
what they themselves it's a weird line
between yes you should be able to wear
what you want makes you feel comfortable
but there is also a responsibility for
you know what you're putting out in the
world and you we were talking just a
minute ago off air there is a difference
between sexiness for a 14 year old which
is I'm going to show everything in
sexiness that in your 20s and 30s and
40s it is a it's a way of being it's an
Essence it's the way I enter a room it's
my sense of humor it's the way I I
gently rest my hand on your arm it's not
just everything I can show you right and
what I think that's also the same with
men when you're younger you want to see
all of it yes as much as possible yeah
but did you learn that sexiness is
confidence and there's something there's
more to it it's it's deeper not just all
of it at the same time but I mean I know
you know as a you know young as a teen
back then I mean yeah you wanted to the
short dress the tight dress the whatever
because that's your idea
and you know what you're doing too you
know the whole you know you're full
fully aware of what you're doing and the
looks you're getting and even at that
age we know yeah yeah
I I've always just been a skinny gangly
dude I never I never got those looks I
never walked into a room in the room
gasp
I put maybe I should wear tighter
clothes I guess
no probably not it's it's different for
men and women
that's fair that's fair what is sexy on
a woman totally different on a man like
a man in a three like a good three-piece
suit
Mercy it's almost like more clothes
the more clothes I wear the better I
look that's that does wonders for my
self-esteem thank you for that Kelly
and that broke my heart all right let's
go to Sarah in Philadelphia what's up
Sarah how we doing
uh you know a river dreams how are you I
am trying my best to not get my show
canceled but Kelly's intent on us not
having a show anymore so what's up
um so I have I have it for you my 14
year old son has expressed an interest
in um and a desire to possibly move in
with his father and I don't think it's a
good idea and of course I don't want him
to go
um but I don't know what to do like is
this something he has to do is this
something I can stop because I don't
think it's what's best for him I don't
know where to go
um number one I hate that I'm sorry for
all of you good grief what a mess it's
been a mess for a long time
yes he just
he's the oldest so I have five kids and
he remembers I mean he doesn't
accurately remember what it was like
when his father and I were together he
thinks it was this beautiful fantasy
land where everything was perfect and
his dad was always there and always
taking care of him and I think he just
wants that but that was never true yeah
of course and he's filled in the gaps
with movies and TV shows and
conversations with his buddies and he
has created a caricature of the man who
was in his life before
his mom screwed everything up and left
and here we are right exactly
um sheesh tell me about Dad
so I'm going to tell you that he's not a
bad dad but he's also not a good dad
he's like in the middle somewhere
um that's hard for me to imagine so give
me some context okay so like
when they go to his house he lives two
hours away so he's not in town so when
they go to his house um every other
weekend so it's 26 weekends a year when
they go to his house they sometimes go
on hikes
um they play a lot of video games they
kind of sit around a lot and play video
games but he does take them for a bike
ride or for a hike normally once during
the weekend
um
and he does reschedule at least five or
six of those weekends a year so it's
kind of like you know I don't have
safety concerns for them when they're at
their dad's house I mean when they were
younger I did but now that they're all
older I don't
um but
but you know the difference you know the
reality he would move into
yeah and like we're you know I
have a husband who I adore and my
husband's been in my kids lives for
um I mean we've been married now for
seven years so
um
like we show up we coach we're on the
sidelines we're cheering for them you
know we're always like I go to all the
school meetings I volunteer I you know I
do all these things to be part of their
lives and to try and make sure that you
know they have the sports they want to
play and stuff like that and like he
does not do that he has never done that
and so but hold on hold on there's some
more to it than that you have to
understand this is not a son making a
statement about his mom
yeah this is not a son making a
statement about his stepdad
this is a son wondering what the hell
was so wrong with me that my dad left
he will spend the rest of his life
trying to solve that problem
even if it means going from stability
and love and connectivity to chaos
yeah he has to
figure out what he did wrong
and it's a hard this is one of those
back-end things why divorce is so tough
even when it's a hundred percent
necessary
is these little ones in the middle are
left wondering what they did to
contribute
and there's no amount of telling them
nothing nothing nothing
especially when the something
is a larger than life figure
23 or 22 times a year
yeah
and does all the cool things that mom
doesn't let us do
well and when he comes to his currently
when my oldest son goes and we do like
my other two sons with my ex-husband
they don't seem to have I mean they're
not as favored as my oldest son by my
ex-husband like my ex-husband took just
my oldest son on vacation last year and
did not take the other two
um
so it's very clear that they're not as
favored as he is
um but when he comes home
from his dads from the weekend it's like
three days of him hating me of course
the re-entry is it's it's yes absolutely
and he says stuff like
now I'm always someone like I
I never badass my ass
point where like that I should ever
badmouth him in front of the kids but to
the point where I think I've kind of
glossed over things that really weren't
okay like
maybe even made the kids feel like you
know if I'm upset I shouldn't be upset
because mom says that Dad loves me and
stuff like that sure
um
but apparently I just found out recently
he's been bad-mouthing me quite a bit
sure and telling the kids that like I
took them away from him and
all this kind of stuff and I was having
a conversation with him with an earshot
of my kids
and he started accusing me of cheating
on him which wasn't true
um and all these other things and I'm
like I'm not going to speak to you about
this right now and he was at my house
and I was like you need to leave my
house right now
um
but it's just like I don't know what to
do because I feel like if he
he moves down there is he just gonna
hate me like he's gonna believe all
these things because I you know never
really discuss this stuff with him so he
doesn't know any other side of the story
right
here's an I I'm just I'm fast forwarding
because this is a complex issue and it's
not one that I can just say yeah you
need to do this or do this
um my gut tells me he needs to stay with
you guys
and my gut tells me that that's going to
come at an extreme relational cost
or to put it more directly there's no
way to win here
and so we're going to do the right thing
even when it's hard
like you see what I'm saying so
um
if I were you
I would tell him I'm willing to consider
this
but we are gonna go you and him are
gonna go see a counselor together for a
minimum of two months three months
whatever
okay and in this conversation the
counselor can help guide the
conversation about living arrangements
why he wants to move maybe then slowly
and gently and appropriately introduce
here's the reality of Dad
sometimes the counselor can ask
questions that
appear to put you on the spot that you
have to answer
um but that
makes the counselor the to the bad guy
if you will and not Mom
not Mom just sitting down at breakfast
live in grenades about Dad but Mom
asking truthful questions about like
yeah dad was abusive
um I had to leave for my own safety or I
had I was trying to keep you guys safe
and all of those are going to be
damaging to him because and you've
probably heard me say this he knows
innately half of him is that guy
and half of him is you and he has to
make that other half right even if that
means glossing over glaring issues like
abuse not showing up rescheduling
forgetting
all you just play video games while I'm
doing some stuff outside like he's gonna
gloss over all of it because he has to
make it right because that's part of him
and if he's not good then I'm not good
okay and it's so messy so messy
that's why I it makes me so sick that he
would talk bad about you
well and that's I I have divorced
parents so when I had like when I split
up for my ex-husband one of the things
we talked about was I was like we can
never bad mouth each other because you
have to remember that half of our kids
are each other
and it makes them feel like that half of
themselves is wrong or bad or that's
horrible exactly and like that's a
horrible horrible feeling to cross like
that I was like I don't like they can't
have that and now like and I don't think
he fits my son down and says like here's
a laundry list of things that are
horrible about your mother he just makes
like
little comments and he makes
significantly more money than I do and
his household makes like probably three
times as much so when they go down there
it's like we can go out to dinner and we
can and it just all adds up into this
this perfect storm of like
my oldest son just eating
our house and being here yeah and he's
just and it's chaotic too there's five
kids two of which are you know someone
else's day like the whole thing and then
yeah you dangle this
um Daddy Warbucks situation in front of
him the whole thing's just a mess and on
top of it I actually think if he sat
your son down and was like your mom's
the worst your son would have some
defense mechanisms
like well hey that's partly me too and
he would think through it and be like
well mom hugs me that's I mean 14 year
olds are pretty Sharp
I think the more Insidious ones are
they're driving and he just puts his
hand on your son's head and tussles his
hair and says wouldn't it be awesome if
we could do this all the time
wouldn't it be cool if your mom would
like let us do this all the time but she
like I mean she went to court and said I
can never see you and that's why we
can't do this all the time
that is the stuff that is Insidious
because there's no comeback for that
and I hate that that's happening to you
I'm sorry the hardest part for you is
going to be not taking this personal
it's a four a 14 year old trying to find
out what he did that was so bad and
trying to figure out why half of him is
so chose to leave
yeah and I'm trying to like not take it
oh I know dude I'm asking you like if
it's me man I would be taking all this
personally
um and you hear me say all the time like
your kids can't make you feel anything
no I feel terrible I would choose to
feel terrible right it's the worst it's
the worst I'm asking you to do the
impossible I know
but that's where I think bringing a
counselor in and be prepared the
counselor may say I think the best thing
is to spend a year there
yeah and y'all you and your new husband
y'all have that conversation would we
allow this what would it look like what
are the rules what are the guidelines
what does the court say about it um you
may get there and I don't know enough
about your son I don't know enough about
your divorce decree and I don't know
enough about
um
what the long-term ramifications would
that would be for him individually and
your family unit
um for him to go away for a year and try
it out
um I've heard of it happening and it's
I've never heard of it going well
like dad's True Colors show themselves
eventually
yeah and he originally my son was
talking about trying it out over the
summer for like one or two months and
here's the thing I've actually offered
to my ex-husband like
you know would you like to have the kids
for like a month during the summer solid
months or like you know six weeks or
something like that so that you can like
really spend time with them
and I always try and give him extra time
whenever there is you know time because
I know that the kids like being down
there
um you know we have behavior problems
with my younger son with him because
when he comes back he's played video
games the whole weekend and he can't
control himself at school of course but
um he's never been interested in taking
me up on this and all of a sudden he's
interested and I think it's because just
recently he changed our support
agreement and he no longer is able to
claim my oldest son on his taxes and it
just cost him like four thousand dollars
on his taxes
um yeah he would if he's doing if he's
doing well financially he wouldn't do
something this dramatic for four
thousand dollars
well
he's not very good with his money
I mean you'd have to be really bad with
mathematics to think a four thousand
dollar tax write-off versus living every
day with a 15 year old is gonna save you
money
I agree I know how expensive my kids are
it's ridiculous yes and he's just now
getting into driver's education and
driving and dating and like he's about
things about to get real expensive
if you think
all the time that the kids
should collected like
like to the shop spending on that and
that and I'm always like of course no
and that's why I said maybe with the
support of a therapist some of those
conversations are going to come out
and maybe maybe you nailed it maybe just
trying in the month of July to see what
it's like
because here's what I'm thinking off top
my head a lot of the data suggests that
when
um a husband and a wife split up and she
takes the kids
her income her net worth goes down his
accelerates exponentially
and generally it's because he can take
as many shifts as he want he can work
overtime he can go get another degree if
he wants he's not trying to tread water
and so it's not uncommon for there to be
a ton of money that just ends up in this
trajectory because he's got no Anchor
Point right he can do what he wants and
then once a weekend I mean once a month
he gets a free-for-all and then go ride
go-karts and play video games and eat
Lucky Charms for every every meal and
then he can just return back to his real
life when you and your family unit have
to absorb the The Fallout from all that
all that to say
um
I think it would be best to sit down
with somebody a professional and say and
tell your son I'm willing to have the
conversation
but there's a lot of the story that you
don't know
and I believe with all of my heart that
the respectful kind thing to do is to
always talk good about your dad and so
I've done that and we're gonna have to
if you wanna if you want me to entertain
this then you're gonna have to go with
me for a period of time with a counselor
and we're gonna have some direct open
conversations and um about you about
your thoughts about your ideas about
safety about my concerns uh and then
we'll go from there off the top of my
head I don't like it it feels like a 15
year old's gonna get dropped off in
Neverland and who knows what happens
next but I'm not an expert here and so I
I want to concede this one to somebody
who's going to have a real good Insight
of you and your family
at the end of the day
I promise you he'll come back
I promise you you're playing a long game
and so six months a year two years he's
gonna come back and he's gonna one day
see
and that woman never gave up on me she
loved me and loved me and tried tried
kept showing up and kept showing up and
kept showing up
hang in there Sarah you he's lucky to
have you we'll be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right we are back um please don't
forget to hit the Subscribe button to uh
if you're on watching this on or
listening to this on Apple or Spotify
please hit the Subscribe button if
you're watching this on YouTube please
hit the Subscribe button and don't
forget those five star reviews if you
got three star reviews just email them
to Kelly and um
she'll probably read them to me because
she loves that when people write in mean
things and she gets to tell me about
them makes her heart feel good
if she had one right just kidding she
does uh all right today's song of the
day
this is the song that that Joe is
running the board he is always always
singing this song
makes everybody uncomfortable his HR
file is something to behold
but it's from his favorite artist The
Great Right Said Fred
[Music]
the song is I'm Too Sexy
and I'll give it a dramatic read
I'm
too sexy for my love
's going to leave me
I'm Too Sexy For My Shirt so sexy it
hurts
I'm too sexy for Milan New York and
Japan
in rhyme red
I'm too sexy for your party no way I'm
disco dancing I'm a model you know what
I mean
and I do my little turn on the catwalk
yeah on the catwalk
I do my little turn on the catwalk
out of your dumb party too sexy for my
car too sexy for my hat what do you
think about that
yeah
I'm Too Sexy Sam I am Green Eggs and Ham
this
if you're ever wondering are we gonna
make it
no we're not we're super not
this was a top top hit
I love you all see you soon
[Music]